i mean i feel fine i just cry myself to
sleep every night
like mother like daughter kourtney
kardashian's daughter penelope reenacted
one of her mother's iconic
keeping up with the kardashians lines on
tick-tock i mean i feel
fine i just cry myself to sleep every
night yeah that's
totally normal here's the original
moment on the reality show where
courtney opened up about the process
of freezing her eggs i mean i feel fine
i just cry myself to sleep every night
yeah that's totally normal now it looks
like courtney's got a blooming tick-tock
star on her hands
though this isn't her first child to
make their mark on tick-tock
okay guys i'm here with mason i'm going
to teach him how to tic-tac
famous relative check courtney's son
mason disick has made a spot for himself
on the app
while busting some moves with his mom
and youtuber david dobrik
[Music]
while courtney herself isn't very active
on tick tock she also parroted the same
iconic scene her daughter did with her
new pal
social media star addison ray i mean i
feel
fine i just cry myself to sleep every
night yeah that's
totally normal throughout quarantine
kardashian and rey have been hanging out
quite a bit e.t spoke with addison last
september where she shared why the age
gap between her and courtney doesn't
affect their friendship
i feel like friendships can range from
any age and
i feel like everyone can relate to
people in different ways and courtney
and i just happen to
have a great friendship which is really
fun and she's been a great
person to have in my life and she she
said in my youtube video that
i had great energy that she liked to be
around but i think she has great energy
as well and she has so much experience
in her life that
i can really just look at and kind of
learn from